so what will theaters do if nobody shows
up for a movie
which actually happens on occasion most
of the time for either a horror movie
and a matinee or a kids movie late at
night nowadays most theaters don't have
like the projector and film reel it's
all just sent to us digitally so you can
just literally pause and stop the movie
and start over and projectors require a
bulb which only work for a certain
number of hours before they have to get
replaced so to save time on the ball
we'll just shut off the movie we usually
wait about half an hour after the start
time just in case anyone comes late but
to the cairns who try and show up
halfway through and then get a discount
saying oh i'm only gonna pay half the
price
stop it karen so if you're trying to
sneak into a horror movie during a
matinee and you're the only one in there
there's a good chance the movie will
just get shut off on you just thought
i'd give you a tip yep things that i
found while cleaning movie theaters that
i wish i hadn't heard one
sushi
whoever this was must have been super
confident because i know from experience
that most of you can't eat popcorn in
the dark without getting it all over
once so i don't know how this person
thought they were gonna
with chopsticks
whatever this might be what some of you
were waiting for
because yeah i found vegetables with
this particular shape i mean it could be
innocent enough you know a lot of people
don't have dinner before they come to
the movie but it didn't even have a bite
taken out of it and if you knew what
movie was playing before i found this
fifty shades
and men's jeans seriously my manager
thought i was joking when i brought this
to the lost and found because really
there's only two ways this scenario
plays out one you brought two pairs of
pants to a movie which is ridiculous for
two somebody took their pants off during
the movie and didn't put them back on
and i live in canada so it is cold
outside in the winter i also found these
in horror movies so it brings a whole
new meaning to the idea of scaring your
pants off oh that's not all of them
worst types of movies when you work at a
movie theater part two i'm honestly sick
of marvel's post-credit scenes not only
do they take up half the time we have to
clean theaters but people think that
every movie has a post privacy now no
your world war ii movie will not be
teasing a sequel
i hope and when a movie doesn't have a
post credit scene people don't believe
us and then they're upset with us that
they had to wait 10 extra minutes just
to watch credits
anyway next up are pg-13 horror movies
when a group of unsupervised middle
schoolers get together to watch a scary
movie my god do they leave a mess
have you ever heard of a popcorn fight
these kids will spend their parents
money on overpriced popcorn and throw it
at each other finally can the emoji
movie please have its own category when
i would stand at the doors to let out
this movie every single parent who came
out looked like they wanted to kill me
for being the one who sold them a ticket
and when karen came out demanding a
refund i almost wanted to let them have
their refund the emoji movie literally
made me take karen's side this movie
broke me
disproving so-called secrets that
apparently movie theaters don't want you
to know about now i worked at a movie
theater for almost five years and so
this is just purely based on personal
experience
so the idea that old popcorn is just
popped and stored away for days to be
sold is completely untrue
in fact one of the things that i didn't
like was how much popcorn we had to
throw out because it wasn't fresh
not only do we not sell popcorn that's
not popped on the same day we would
throw it out if it wasn't popped for
your particular showtime
another one is that somehow kids can
sneak into r-rated movies just by buying
a ticket for a kid's movie and going
into the other theater like ushers know
what they're doing
you think we don't notice when a bunch
of 13 year old boys wearing deadpool
shirts go buy a ticket for kung fu panda
3
plus if a kid does manage to sneak into
an r-rated movie they always sit in the
back corner with their hood up
it's like at least pretend you're
supposed to be there
you